we begin this half-hour with alarming
data about our roads new research from
triple-a finds deaths from red light
running increased 28 percent from 2012
to 2017
studies have shown camera enforcement
can cut red light running by more than
20% and now here in New York City there
are more than 200 speed cameras set up
with a plan for that to increase to more
than 2,000 by 2021
but as Kris Van Cleave reports some want
the city to pump the brakes dangerous
driving caught by New York City's speed
cameras this car hits 78 in a 25 and
this Mercedes raced through a school
zone at nearly 60 miles an hour
if you don't speed you won't get a
ticket
Evelyn cancels six-year-old son Dante
was killed by a driver going more than
double the speed limit in the Bronx that
reckless driver that speedy driver he
didn't only kill Dante he killed the
entire cansel family this camera goes
off if somebody does what if they're
going over ten miles over the speed
limit Transportation Commissioner Polly
trottenberg is overseeing the city's
camera crackdown a roughly tenfold
increase in the number of speed cameras
there's putting thousands of speed
cameras on New York City streets turn
New York into just one big speed trap I
guess I have to really disagree with the
characterization of speed trap were
thoughtful and data-driven about where
we put the cameras we're not trying to
have a game of gotcha
are those locations on your website nope
you say you don't want it to be a gotcha
program but you don't want to tell
people where the cameras are which makes
it seem like a gotcha program I disagree
but okay the goal of the program is to
get people to drive safely all over New
York City
I want that halo effect from the cameras
at least 140 to communities in fifteen
states use speed cameras
New York City's cameras have brought in
more than 250 million in fines so far
but the city says 80% of those who get a
$50 ticket never get another one critics
argue cameras can cause a spike in
rear-end collisions but the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety found in 80
percent reduction in excessive speeding
reduced red light running and if
fifteen to twenty percent cut in crashes
but just this summer Texas became the
eighth state to crack down on camera
enforcement by banning red-light cameras
I think it's about the money
arlington resident Kelley cannon spent
years fighting for the ban after she got
a $75 ticket I call it government
sanctioned extortion for Evelyn canceled
who pushed for the New York City speed
cameras it's all about the hope another
family won't experience her heartbreak I
call it the forever pain because it
doesn't go away
we checked several camera locations and
there are street signs warning drivers
that they're coming the cameras take
pictures of the car in the license plate
but not the driver the $50 fine is sent
to the car's registered owner for CBS
this morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
New York I've gotten a ticket for on a
red-light camera and here's the thing I
ran the red light it's one of those you
know where you're slowing down you don't
know should I slow or go faster this you
broke the law if you broke the law
you're going to learn I don't think
anybody would argue that it's a good
thing to run red lights no right it's
not a good thing
I should matter but it's amazing ten
times as many speed cameras two years
from now in New York it's assumed that's
gonna be similar across the country it's
a lot yeah well the government I guess
will they'll get richer because that is
their bad when people break the law Yeah
right that's down on the numbers that's
the thing that well honestly for safety
yeah we want our streets to be safer